former vice president joe biden is
accusing president trump of
outing of quitting rather on the country
during the pandemic
the presumptive democratic presidential
nominee made the comment as he
unveiled a plan that he says will help
restore the economy
and o'keefe joins us from washington ed
what's in this plan
hey anthony good morning the 775 billion
dollar plan is designed to help working
parents and caregivers
with new ideas for expanding pre-k and
access to care
for kids and the elderly it also
promises to create about three million
new jobs
and by targeting the economic
uncertainty caused by the pandemic
the binding campaign is hoping to draw
sharper contrasts with the president
donald trump fails the most important
test of being an american president
the duty to care
for you joe biden once again slammed
president trump's handling of the
pandemic
he's quit on you and he's quit on this
country
the former vice president on tuesday
spoke from a school in his native
delaware
and he once again focused on the economy
but
this time he unveiled plans to create
three million new jobs to help care for
the nation's kids
senior citizens and disabled this is
about
easing the squeeze on working families
biden's proposals would expand access to
at home care
push for universal public
pre-kindergarten and hire at least 35
000 people
to help tackle the opioid epidemic the
speech came as biden is more closely
scrutinizing options for a running mate
set to be announced in august he says
he's reviewing background files on each
contender
then i'm going to narrow the uh uh the
uh
the list and uh and then we'll see and
then i'm going to have personal
discussions with
tynan's potential picks include black
white latino and
asian american women like congresswoman
val demings
atlanta mayor keisha lance bottoms and
senator tammy duckworth
buzz around them means they're getting
more exposure to a wider audience
he's going to pick the right person to
help him run and and serve this country
and i will continue to serve in any way
that i can i'm honored to be in the
conversation
and i'm going to do everything in my
power to make sure joe biden is elected
the next president united states
one other note biden in an interview
with our milwaukee tv station last night
confirmed that he will be in that city
next month
to accept the democratic party's
presidential nomination
tony all right ed thank you very much